quand je dis greg adeline greg craig
les amis il est en meurent faire un saut
sur les petites perles de craigslist
parce que j'avais beaucoup aimé sa
dernière fois les américains sont
farfelues sont un petit peu fou fou ce
sont de vrais ouistiti des zigotos sur
quoi nous allons tomber aujourd'hui la
question est totale on y va vintage
chuck i ching showbiz pizza la dernière
fois j'avais des animatronics était dans
sa ville natale freddy's et ça m'a pas
trop plu
oh là là mais c'est glauque as fuck
je sais pas si c'est glauque en soi ou
si c'est à cause de farinette afridi ce
que aulas n'ont su glauque en soi non me
la fait pas aucun enfant est ravi de
voir ça vraiment je suis sûr mais c'est
un vraiment un truc de ouf qui doit
coûter hyper cher regardez c'est
vraiment complet quoi regarde ça mec
j'ai pas envie d'entendre chanter ce
truc
les cas cette date de 1985 je sais pas
comment leur faire marcher leur fais
jamais marcher mais qu'il ya au moins
800 démons qui vont venir posséder ta
maison sur craigslist il ya un truc que
j'avais pas dire derrière fois c'est que
des fois les gens utilisent craigslist
pour retrouver quelqu'un vous faire
passer un message à quelqu'un l'a par
exemple c'est un mec qui alla à
l'hôpital et qui adresse un message à
quelqu'un qu'il a vu là bas c'était dans
la nuit de jeudi
j'avais une infection urinaire et tu
étais comme hermione harry potter tu
m'as comme jeter un sort avec ta
baguette à ultrasons j'étais venu avec
mon copain mais je le quitterai pour toi
car tu sais comment faire marcher les
choses
dis-moi de quelle taille était le kit
sur mon mauvais et je saurai que c'est
toi et niall j'adore aulas il vend un
bateau de 9 mètres gratuits grand père
était un marin il vivait loin de la mer
et a donc loué une grue pour laisser
tomber un voilier dans sa piscine
il est temps de sortir le bateau gratuit
pour toute personne qui arrive à enlever
le bateau soit endommagé le mur ou ce
qui est autour
ce groupe est génial le mec est têtu
c'est un vrai grand père [ __ ] c'est
incroyable je trouve ça fabuleux je
pense que je suis grand-père choix là
même si je veux une motoneige du match
prend une motoneige neige ou pas je m'en
bats les couilles
un autre message que quelqu'un adresse à
un autre mais cette fois c'est mignon
sera négatif en 2009 j'ai adopté ce
chien a une famille qui vivait à saint
charles
le 13 février 2009 je suis venu chez
vous le chercher j'ai promis à votre
fille que je lui donnerai tout l'amour
que j'ai et que sa vie serait belle
aujourd'hui il fait entièrement partie
de la famille
on partage nos journées ensemble et même
de vacances récemment on a découvert
qu'il avait des problèmes de coeur et de
respiration aujourd'hui il a perdu sa
bataille et on a dû lui dire au revoir
je vous ai toujours été reconnaissants
de nous avoir donné le chien le plus
aisément mignon et sympathique qui n'ait
jamais existé au dossier des photos il
est trop mignon
pourquoi j'ai mis ça [ __ ] vie rires ça
tue l ambiance là haut une kia optima de
2014 avec quelques dommages à l'arrière
ça sent le guet-apens
la voiture marche nickel et rule 34
mille kilomètres au compteur
transmission automatique 4 cylindres je
demande 4500 dollars non mais mais mais
t'as pas honte
quelques dommages à l'arrière bon gars
athema tonkov vieux os
non mes mecs ces abus tu peux même pas
vous les regards pour d'échappement mec
le skate de la mort monfils a construit
sa pour lui et ses copains vous vous
allongez dessus et descendez les rues
pavées lui et ses amis sont tous blessés
maintenant le mec t'es ma la planche
quoi elle fait rêver solberg
elle est horrible ils ont mis des
[ __ ] drood roller et en bas des roues
de skate cross un projet unique en son
genre une voiture me corvette mi avion
un avion de 63 une corvette de 84
inattendu unique en son genre
[Musique]
mec c'est chaud c'est un scandale qu'on
pense que dans son esprit ça donnait un
truc trop stylé trop beau et tout une
fois qu'il l'a fait la regarder il a mis
sur craiglist adam sort thaïlandais de
la masculinité hockey arrêtez tout est
réfléchi ces composés vous observez le
danseur thaïlandais de la masculinité
regarder dans ses yeux il est celui que
vous attendiez il vous restera il vous
guérir à il regardera dans votre âme et
apaisera cette douleur voix comme il te
sourit il m'a soigné je dois maintenant
le passé à quelqu'un d'autre
comme il me l'a demandé alors je n'ai
aucune idée de ce que c'est que cette
sculpture c'est peut-être un truc hyper
connue là-bas ou ou pas mais cela dit je
pense très fortement cet objet posé des
mecs tu me dis embrasser annabelle ou ce
danseur j'embrasse annabelle il veut
vendre sa [ __ ] de voitures ok c'est
une jeep personnes feraient la gueule en
ayant cette voiture est très cool mais
pour lui ce n'est pas assez lui il veut
la vendre
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand vendre une
voiture à tout prix on fait des photos
montages on la foule dans mad max mon
gars et oui regardez ça comme c'est bien
incrusté ce mec cadrage je vais acheter
sa voiture juste pour sa sympathie
j'écris ceci au cas où tu aimerais faire
partie de la vie de notre enfant bien
tonné je suis mexican american je
faisais un mètre soixante dix pour 65 kg
quand on a fait l'amour
j'ai essayé de te dessinée je ne sais
pas faire deux portraits-robots comme la
police mais je pense que la ressemblance
est là elle a flingué même s'il voulait
revenir maintenant il veut plus revenir
il a vu le peu d'estimé gala pour lui il
a du stock qui n'a jamais rêvé par
costume de coupe ongles mec moi il m'en
faut un de cette taille pour couper mes
ongles de pieds je vous ai dégoté une
phrase en plus un sport d'hiver nul à
chier ces meilleurs costumes buts à j'ai
trouvé la pire photo pour représenter
une annonce vraiment cet homme voit une
public a tre 20 regardez attentivement
cette photo il tient la pillerie 80 dans
sa baignoire et son chat est en plein
milieu de la photo de plus cet homme est
nu vents forts fait maison
ma copine m'a dit qu'elle voulait me
parler à propos de mon comportement de
gamin mais elle ne connaissait pas le
mot de passe pour pouvoir rentrer dans
le ford lefort inclus à wii fit et une
belle vue sur la télé pour regarder
netflix protégé par un gros chien
méchant sauf si vous avez de la pizza
ayem photo du chien
we've en fauteuil à moitié mangé mon
chien a mangé une partie de mon fauteuil
et il n'a pas du tout l'air désolé je
pars est la mère d'entre vous mais mec
j'avoue il
battle écoute bien c'est que ça c'est ma
hantise et natsu j'ai trop peur que ça
arrive devant 6-2 marche parfaitement
point fort peu importe quelle coupe elle
ne s'arrête jamais point faible la
protection fonctionne mal de manière
aléatoire
c'est probablement facile à réparer
perdu deux doigts tu ne peux pas dire ça
ne la vends pas alt a pris 2 doit déjà
besoin de couches de poulet avez vous
chez vous des poulets ou des canards bah
non non avez vous besoin de les équiper
de couches pour garder votre maison
propre nom n'ont toujours pas puisque
j'ai pas de nous faisons des couches
customisé pour poules et canards
disponible en différents coloris
[Musique]
vandomme restaurée entre parenthèses
peut être hanté j'ai reçu de ma
grand-mère et il était dans un piètre
état
toutes les plantes semble mourir autour
de lui mais les enfants très mal à
l'aise a une petite chance d'être
possédé
il écrit pis as fuck mon gars qui met de
mazagan et l'inde de faire
il ad'ailleurs vague alors cette
figurine vent chaise de la mort mais en
quoi cette chaise de la mort ah non mais
sans déconner imagine un mec s'assoit
dessus parce qu'il est bourré il a pas
fait exprès non mais sans ils ont mis
des lames de rasoir au milieu mais qu
une table basse unique qui blessera vos
enfants les mecs ont encore fait pas une
table avec deux fois plus d'angle qu'une
table normale pour que ton gosse est
deux fois plus de chances de se péter le
crâne dessus apporte chaussures
customisée en titre vacant ce qui la
fait tu croises l'avant de la pompe
dedans et c'est bon c'est vraiment pas
content non c'est glauque s'écrit pis ça
c'est avec beaucoup de tristesse que je
dois donner mes poupées grandeur nature
et anatomiquement correct que j'ai
acheté il ya des années quand je me
sentais seul je suis maintenant marié ma
femme m'a dit qu'elles doivent partir
leurs prénoms sont suzy ça qu'il ya
est-elle chic mais pose pas avec elle en
q les pardons pas pourquoi il pose avec
elle ça n'a pas de sens mais ça fait
rêver personne
on arrive très bien à visualiser ce que
tu as fait avec la
[Musique]
parachute gratuit je vends un parachute
100% fonctionnel il ne s'est pas ouvert
lors de mon dernier saut après l'avoir
ramassé sur le korn vérifier qu'il y
avait aucun problème pour les
utilisations vide sur ces drôles
c'est une petite blague drôle sauf si
quelqu'un est vraiment mort parce qu'il
ne s'est pas ouvert je vends un orgue
l'ida 400 dollars
[Musique]
ça me fait tu pense qu'en voyant tu
habites collée au dos du piano tu as
plus de chances de le vendre c'est ça de
la stratégie mike les amis ont fini la
vidéo sur un item trop stylé une [ __ ]
de rood hamster à taille humaine
pourquoi courir sur un tapis roulant
quand tu peux acheter une roue [ __ ]
les a mais c'est la fin de cette
deuxième vidéo sur les annonces
américaines je crois qu'on a torché
craigslist ya pas une annonce qui nous a
échappé par contre résout mais ça ça
m'avait échappé
n'hésitez pas mm d'eau ciel vous a plu
je vous fais plein de gros bisous
n'hésitez pas à vendre vos objets sur
craigslist
personne ne les achètera par contre les
gens font des vidéos sur vos annonces
pour se moquer de vous je suis une merde
en vrai on rigole mais c'est toujours
une tannée de vendre un truc sur un site
comme leboncoin ou quoi et je trouve que
quand tu rajoutes de l'humour même si
ton produit et péter de mecs qui
cherchent des objets sur le site ils
passaient moins mais en moments aussi
une morale de merde ça c'est moral de
merde
et qu'est ce qu'on dit après une belle
morale de merde comme ça
[Musique]